In this exercise, you'll make a river flow. Well, it's more like a square lake
than a river and really the texture should be more stretched to look like
flowing water and the banks of the river - well, well never mind. This is an
exercise after all so I want to keep it simple. The initial code doesn't have
anything moving. Your job is to use the texture transform feature in Three.js
to animate the water as shown, moving from top to bottom. The rate of movement
is one second per copy of the texture. In other words, when the texture repeat
is three, a point at the top of the square will take three seconds to move from
top to bottom. When the repeat is changed to one, the top of the texture moves
down the screen in one second. For your solution, the movement should be tied
to the elapsed time in the real world. If you look just above where your code
should go, you'll see how the texture repetition parameter is set on the
texture. You'll need similar code in your solution.